in sonthofen im allgäu stehen seit
jahren diese fußgänger ampeln
das besondere hier regeln keine
ampelmännchen den fußgängerverkehr
sondern ampelfrauen rot heißt stehen
grün heißt gehen alles kein problem
sollte man meinen weil die ampel frauen
aber kein staatlich anerkanntes
lichtsignal sind sollen sie jetzt wieder
weg dass man das jetzt verändern sollte
das finde ich lächerlich und es auch mal
immer wieder auch ein hingucker
dass die leute mal ihr genau auf die
ampel schauen ich finde es sehr schade
ich finde es toll dass es das gibt am
bild frauentag 2013 ersetzt die stadt an
zwei fußgänger überwiegen die dürren
ampelmännchen durch starke frauen fünf
jahre läuft alles reibungslos keine
unfälle kein fußgänger kommt zu schaden
doch im frühjahr werden die allgäuer
ampelfrauen von der regierung von
schwaben entdeckt ein blick in die
richtlinien für lichtsignalanlagen zeigt
fußgänger ampeln sind nur mit männchen
erlaubt die ampelfrau ist kein
offizielles zeichen sie muss wieder weg
der sonthofener bürgermeister christian
wilhelm hält die forderung für
abenteuerlich tatsache ist aber schon
dass wir viele bürger halt rückmelden
dass ihnen die andere anlage schon ans
herz gewachsen ist lebensnotwendig ist
das sicher nicht aber im grundsatz geht
es um emotionalität an der stelle und
wir setzen uns als bürgermeister sich
irgendeine verpflichtung und politischer
träger auch so sehen vielleicht zu
stoppen
in augsburg bei der regierung von
schwaben bleibt man dabei in der ampel
haben frauen nichts zu suchen
grundsätzlich muss unter dem
gesichtspunkt der verkehrssicherheit die
symbolik klar und eindeutig sein und
darf keine ablenkenden elemente
enthalten damit sie in kürzester zeit
erfasst werden kann
die menschen im allgäu wissen sehr genau
wann und wie sie über die straße gehen
dürfen
ich finde es eigentlich sinnlos weil mir
geht es eigentlich darum ist es grün
oder rot ich schaue doch da am ende oder
weiblich da kann man seine geistigen
kapazitäten nehme an für was anderes
verwenden
in sonthofen werden schon
erinnerungsfotos gemacht dabei sollen
die ampel frauen bleiben wo sie sind
die stadt wird sie nicht entfernen das
müsste die regierung von schwaben dann
schon selbst in die hände nehmen
in etlichen anderen städten gibt es
schließlich noch viel wildere versionen
vom ampelmännchen